how much fun you guys having here in  Vegas we love coming yeah we come to  Vegas a lot actually yeah we were down  here a few weeks ago to see ac/dc and we  come down to see somebody do a CBC  not now are you guys gamblers are you  indulging a little bit like she's very  good are what you're getting good I have  a little amount of money and I go and  bet that and then then I'm done I'm not  going to gambler well that's the way to  do it a bit the house we are so excited  for the new album tracklist is finally  out do you have a favorite song on the  album oh I mean it is such a crazy good  album I have to say I've been living  with all the songs and even the song she  didn't make the album yeah it's just  like an abundance but I've seen him you  know the work that he puts into it and  the love and he's a musician so every  little tiny detail is is all him yeah I  love that I love that he's that  passionate about his music so do you  like you rushing